le 31 décembre l'europe devra adopter la
prochaine politique agricole commune
elle représentera plus de 350 milliards
d'euros pour nourrir les européens mais
pas seulement
elle devra également accélérer la
transition de notre système agricole en
préservant les économies rurales et en
prenant en compte les impératifs
écologiques nous jdem avons voulu
rencontrer les acteurs de terrain pour
voir comment les agriculteurs et plus
largement tous les acteurs de la fourche
à la fourchette agissent pour répondre
aux nombreux enjeux auxquels ils font
face aujourd'hui
l'écologie c'est aussi une question
vraiment très pratique il ya un cas que
le souhaiteraient partager avec vous
comme vous le savez il y avait la
question des épandages et la distance de
sécurité qui devait être mise en place
entre les cultures et les habitations
charte qui a été signé entre les
sculpteurs c'est à dire les producteurs
de noix et les syndicats agricoles la
chambre d'agriculture le département est
bien évidemment une association de
riverains et ils se sont tous mis
d'accord et ils ont signé cette charte
en décembre 2019 pour mettre une
distance de 50 mètres entre les
épandages et les habitations
donc on voit que quand les acteurs
semaine tous autour de la table
eh bien on arrive à trouver des
solutions qui conviennent puisqu'on sait
que notamment la multiculture cd
économiquement un secteur très important
et on sait aussi que les habitants sont
extrêmement soucieux de la préservation
de leur environnement
et ça marche les exemples locaux
montrent qu'on peut arriver à trouver
des solutions pour tout le monde ce
souci de préservation de l'environnement
doit être soutenue par nos institutions
les régions reçoivent des fonds
agricoles de l'union européenne qu'ils
doivent réallouer aux acteurs locaux
mais le soutien aux démarches de
protection des eaux et des sols n'a de
sens que s'il est constant mais leur
conviction que le bio ça marche
on considère qu'il ya tout un tas de
services environnementaux affaire de
pollution des eaux de coutume des sols
sur terre au niveau sanitaire des
maladies qui peuvent être provoquées par
certains produits on en parle de
suffisamment les médias pour le savoir
même au niveau social parce que comme je
vous le disais le bio permet de
rémunérer plus de d'actifs que le
conventionnel en rapport avec la surface
de culture ou production et donc tous
ces services rendus
on continue devraient à partir du moment
où l'agriculture toucher des subventions
publiques
on considère que le bio devrait en
toucher un peu plus en rapport avec ses
services qui soit rendue pour pallier au
manque de subventions dédiées à
l'agriculture biologique
les agriculteurs innove en trouvant de
nouveaux modèles économiques à l'instar
des circuits courts on enlève tous les
intermédiaires donc le prix au final est
plutôt même souvent moins cher qu'en
deux camps ont fait 50 circuits longs et
en même temps nous on récupère la valeur
ajoutée donc pas dans la poche des
intermédiaire c'est pour cela que franck
wang au nouveau maire de fontaine a
choisi de mener une politique
volontariste en allant au delà des
nouveaux objectifs fixés par la loi et
en garantissant 100 % de bio ou de local
dans les cantines scolaires elle comme
une saine gestion du quotidien déjà et
les villes où aujourd'hui notamment la
gestion des cantines ou des
établissements de personnes âgées
je pense aux résidences autonomie donc
quand on parle de ces établissements
forcément on parle de restauration on
parle de restauration scolaire
évidemment notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui les données des repas de
qualité ont bien qu' une tendance quand
même à se déplacer vers la nourriture
locale la nourriture bio c'est quand
même des enjeux importants aujourd'hui
on parle de bouleversements climatiques
on parle de consommer mieux de polluer
moins pour qu'on ait directement nous
concernant il faut qu'on soit acteur on
propose 20% de bio dans l'ensemble de
nos repas et on va tendre vers 50 % dans
les deux ans à venir pour arriver à la
fin du mandat dans six ans 100 % de bio
ou de local on doit trouver évidemment
les fournisseurs on ironisait on a la
chance d'avoir des montagnes à côté bien
sûr d'agriculture
et donc on travaille en local pour
rechercher ceux qui peuvent nous fournir
nous on agit en responsabilité même si
ça coûte un petit peu plus cher la
commune et bain par exemple le mois
dernier on a augmenté la chasse
communale des repas de 30 centimes donc
on a mis nous un petit peu plus d'argent
pour acheter une plus grande part de bio
dans nos cantines scolaires le lien
entre le consommateur et l'agriculteur
induit de la réciprocité
l'agriculteur est responsable de la
qualité des produits
le consommateur est responsable de la
qualité de vie de celui qui sur
l'exploitation une élève surtout
essentiellement
la vache qui s'appelle la villard de
lans donc originaires du pays c'est une
race qui a failli disparaître ce qui
fait partie de la biodiversité
chez nous avec ont produit de la viande
est sur le plateau du vercors notamment
avec ils produisent du lait pour la
hausse et du bleu du vercors sassenage
mais pour moi aujourd'hui un jeune qui
se lancent hors cadre familial
s'il n'est pas vraiment bien accompagné
ça peut l'empêcher de se lancer dans
l'élevage quoi ou dans l'agriculture en
général ces dix dernières années plus de
soixante dix mille agriculteurs parti à
la retraite n'ont pas été remplacés
c'est un enjeu majeur pour l'avenir de
ce secteur dont nous dépendons
nécessairement mais ces témoignages sont
pour nous la preuve qu'il est possible
de créer des synergies entre
agriculteurs citoyens et acteurs locaux
ce sont ces modèles devrait encourager
la prochaine politique agricole commune
louis dreux dont je suis maître de
conférences en droit de l'environnement
à agroparistech et chercheur à
l'université paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
et mon champ de recherche particulier ce
sont des questions notamment relatives à
la protection de la biodiversité au sein
de l'université 133 je suis rapporteur
de l'atelier développement durable et
cet atelier couvre le champ économique
social et environnemental dont compte
tenu des circonstances particulières
nous avons mené des auditions et des
auditions par visioconférence un certain
nombre de personnalités qui sont soit
engagée au modem soit proche des idées
centristes que ce soit des enseignants
chercheurs des élus nationaux des élus
locaux ou des personnalités qui
s'intéressent à ces questions à
l'analyse de ces auditions nous avons
aussi ajouté
le rendu des militants du modem qui se
sont exprimés sur ces thématiques
chaque génération a un enjeu à porter
pour la d'autres incontestablement ça
sera le celui d'un développement durable
c'est à dire un développement économique
assumer mais équitable une protection
aussi de notre société avec une
recherche de l'apaisement
je pense que c'est important surtout
dans les circonstances actuelles
et puis bien évidemment la protection de
l'environnement notre environnement qui
inclut notre espèce de vie mais aussi
ses composantes naturelles comme la
biodiversité alors le développement
durable il faut pas le condamner à la
transition écologique la transition
écologique est un pan du développement
durable qui est très important en fait
l'idée de développement durable c'est
d'avoir un développement équilibré
aujourd'hui par exemple si on prend
l'exemple de la précarité énergétique
on sait qu'on a des immeubles qui sont
des passoires thermiques et évidemment
c'est du perdant perdant c'est du
perdant pour l'environnement puisque on
dépense de l'énergie mais c'est dû
perdre on sait pour ses habitants qui
ont souvent peu de moyens qui peuvent
pas rénové qui donc se chauffent mal et
le peu qui chauffe il chauffe dehors
donc évidemment il ya des stratégie
gagnant gagnant a trouvé entre le
développement économique qui portent
l'innovation la lutte contre la pauvreté
par l'accessibilité à ces nouvelles
technologies qui permettent en même
temps de protéger l'environnement dans
tout ça fait système
en matière de développement durable la
famille centriste a une pensée à
apporter notamment en ce qui concerne la
place de l'homme qui est central mais
aussi des questions liées à
l'organisation politique des notions de
décentralisation de partage du pouvoir
d'innovation et tout simplement de
respect de la liberté de chacun
d'entreprendre et d'innover donc autour
de cette notion de progrès évidemment ce
s'ajoute la notion de croissance et je
suis persuadé nous sommes persuadés ici
en tout cas c'est ce qui ressort des
entretiens que l'on a mené et du rendu
des militants qu'il est possible de
trouver un chemin où l'on concilie
progrès croissance protection de
l'environnement et mon meilleur et que
évidemment nous ne sommes pas condamnés
au vivre dans un monde durable
hadley décroissance un retour en arrière
mais qu'il s'agit bien à travers le
développement durable d'une révolution
écologique qui nous permet d'avancer
davantage et non pas de reculer sur ce
chemin du progrès humaniste seul le
mouvement démocrate par son histoire et
ses vertus qui sont celles de la
modération
celle de l' équilibre peut porter une
voix qui concilie les enjeux d'un
développement durable vraiment humain
avec la protection de notre planète de
notre économie et d'une société où il
fait bon vivre ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toutes et à tous bienvenue à ses
universités de rentrée un peu
particulière pour le pour le modèle mais
kobe d'obliger le numérique va nous va
nous permettre de travailler en commun
très belle plénière qui s'annonce avec
de très beaux invités et donc le thème
aujourd'hui c'est sauver nos emplois
préservés la planète partager nos
richesses alors on va échanger sous une
forme un peu particulière évidemment on
va avoir de beaux invités puisqu'on aura
d'abord marguerite et préau de berre
mode gatel à mme thérèse silva zermane
et on conclura pas yann wehrling on va
demander à chacun de nos invités de
parler pendant 4 à 5 minutes chacun et
ensuite on fera et on lancera le débat
sur le sujet simplement vous dire que
cette thématique de ce jour et est quand
même particulier on voit bien qu les les
enjeux aujourd'hui environnementaux
sociétaux économiques sont importants et
donc mélanger un petit peu ce que l'on a
fait c'est à dire les problèmes
économiques avec des problèmes
écologiques
ça nous avait paru très très important
alors on va commencer par évidemment
marguerite deprez au de berre donc
marguerite tu es députés modem tu siège
à la commission des affaires économiques
est-ce que tu m'entends déjà je
travaille je ne te vois pas ah je moi je
ne maîtrise pas la technique donc j'en
suis vraiment désolé mais tant qu'on
s'entend peut-être que toi tu verra donc
marguerite tu va intervenir évidemment
sur le thème quitté cher c'est à dire
l'économie tué une vieille tradition à
béthune d'industriels ou humé un petit
peu nous parlait évidemment marguerite
deux à la fois l'industrie des les docks
des délocalisations et expliquer un peu
que finalement quand un industriel est
installé c'est beaucoup d'emplois et
puis tu as souvent dit que tu en voulez
pas aux industriels d'être parti mais
souvent élus et donc on va s'entendre
sur le sujet sur la localisation et sur
le fait qu'il faut peut-être rien du str
et les arts france je vais te laisser la
parole marguerite
ok d'avenches bonjour à tous et merci
c'est un peu désagréable parce que là je
m'entends en retour en écho donc c'est
un peu compliqué enfin je vais essayer
de me débrouiller
effectivement en béthune a occupé
l'actualité chaude de cette semaine
parce que béthune est un arrondissement
industrielle où je suis né et donc c'est
un arrondissement nous le pib industriel
est le plus important du pas de calais
et peut-être des hauts de france et il
leur il était jusqu à la semaine
dernière mais comme la première usine de
du secteur va fermer cette porte est
annoncée la semaine dernière
il faut à tout prix faire en sorte que
ce territoire garde son identité
industrielle et se projette dans le
futur en devenant un territoire
d'industries comme l'a proposé le
gouvernement deux enfants suivant la
stratégie du gouvernement
ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'industrie s'est effectivement c'est
beaucoup d'emplois à la clé tout emploi
industriel par exemple bridgestone c'est
863 en point mais auto en au total
s'affairer le plus près de 2000 familles
qui sont impactés par cette par cette
fermeture
ce canton et on a eue l'industrie quand
on produit derrière il ya la sécurité il
ya la maintenance et les espèces
d'entretien des espaces verts et à la
cantine
il ya l'entretien il ya là les pièces
mécaniques à réparer enfin autant de
services qui sont nécessaires pour la
bonne
la bonne conduite de ceux de ces
entreprises donc c'est beaucoup
d'emplois plus tous les emplois
évidemment qui sont classiques qui sont
liées à la vie économique à béthune
bridgestone a rempli sa mission pendant
disons plus de 5 tout cinquante années
près de soixante années parce que ça
fait soixante ans que c'est en
entreprise existe elle a contribué
beaucoup au tissu local
ne serait-ce que pas les versements de
salaires s'étaient encore 40 50 millions
l'année dernière c'était six millions et
demi de taxe pour les collectivités que
qui on était bien contente de toucher 7
cette manne donc moi je pense que cette
entreprise a fait son devoir
effectivement il ya un problème de sous
investissement qui était visible depuis
plusieurs années mais là on interfèrent
le contexte européen et le contexte
mondial en entreprise il faut qu'elle
tienne compte du marché
avant tout il a fonctionné pendant 50
ans c'est parce qu'à l'époque
bethune était ou au coeur de l'europe du
nord-ouest
le marché s'est déplacé vers l'est comme
vous savez tous et même vers le maroc
négocie donc tout change
hélas l entreprise doit s'adapter alors
est-ce que tu maintenant il sait qu
enfin oui oui
marguerite quand tu disais tout à
l'heure et que entre collectivités élus
et entreprises sur cette responsabilité
finalement qui incombent aux uns ou aux
autres
on peut avoir l'impression que
l'entreprise n'a pas joué le jeu dans
ses investissements du futur en faisant
des bas de gamme ou est ce que tu penses
que la collectivité les élus en
particulier n'ont pas répondu présent à
cette entreprise
je pense que on a fait un petit peu le
l'autruche en fait les élus gouverner
c'est prévoir
donc il fallait anticiper on sait très
bien que la filière automobile qui chez
nous à remplacer la mine
ses jours sont quand même papa limites
que conté mais elle évolue donc on sait
très bien que le marché du pneu peut
être que baissier quand on fait tout
tout ce qu'on peut pour favoriser les
transports en commun pour favoriser le
vélo pour le covoiturage on sait très
bien qu'on est amis avoir moins de
voitures donc moins de pneus je pense
que françois bayrou peut très bien
comprendre est que dans ces missions sa
verts eelv est dans le coeur du marché
s'il y avait eu un élan pour les lésés
loi et l'entreprise elle a profité des
fonds européens pour investir
en pologne là où ils sont marché devenu
son marché naturel parce que bridgestone
malheureusement vent très peu de en
france mais son marché ce sont les arts
les automobiles allemandes et donc la
pologne l'allemagne sont quand même très
sont quand même très proches et surtout
que c'était moins cher et en pologne
travaille 40 heures par semaine et à
béthune ont travaillé 32 heures par
semaine donc la messe était dite pour
moi même merci marguerite on va prendre
les nos invités sur cette table ronde et
puis on fera le le débat après mode est
ce que tu peux nous dire évidemment de
mots donc me tuer élus d'île de france
tu es élu de paris est et on a souvent
entendu parler entre eux j'ai envie de
dire entre économie et ce qui est en
train de se jouer sur le développement
durable et soutenable d'une remise en
question quasiment de l'économie
libérale telle qu'on l'a imaginé et donc
que tu as souvent penser que finalement
il fallait penser global on a entendu
parler de beaucoup de ça pour essayer de
réagir locale qu'est ce que tu peux le
dire toi à paris comment tu imagines ça
et comment globalement puisque c'est un
peu ton sujet tu penses que l'économie
doit se modifier pour modifier nos
comportements
merci beaucoup richard bonjour à tous
comme le comme le rappelait
effectivement marguerite on voit bien
que la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui se
double d'une accélération de la crise
sociale économique
marguerite par les bridgestone on pense
évidemment aussi à airbus
un certain nombre de tpe pme et
malheureusement ça ça risque de
s'accélérer alors ya des nids certaines
voix se font entendre
demandant à ce que on reporte les
engagements notamment en matière
environnementale qui ont été pris moi je
pense que notre responsabilité c'est au
contraire d'affirmer que la transition
écologique est une chance pour notre
modèle économique et pour nos emplois
pour moi opposé fin du monde et fin du
mois ça n'a aucun sens d'abord parce que
et on l'a vu ces derniers mois et on va
continuer malheureusement de le voir
parce que en période de crise sont
toujours des plus fragiles qui sont le
plus touchés et puis parce que ça
voudrait dire qu'on ne peut pas avancer
sur un des sujets
co dépens de l'autre or je pense que
c'est précisément l'un verse on ne
répondra aux enjeux économiques et
sociaux d'aujourd'hui et de demain qu'en
poursuivant des objectifs
environnementaux extrêmement fort la
crise sanitaire par son ampleur
totalement inédite et malgré
l'accompagnement de l'état et on peut
d'ailleurs se réjouir de de vivre en
france avec un modèle social aussi
développer cette crise elle a révélé un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements de
notre modèle de développement
elle a aussi creusé les inégalités entre
ceux qui ont eu la possibilité
d'économiser près de 100 milliards
d'euros
ces derniers mois et ceux qui au
contraire ont souffert dès les premiers
jours
dès les premiers jours du du confinement
alors moi j'ai envie de voir cette
période comme une formidable opportunité
pour pour réduire les fractures qu'elle
soit sociale territoriale et je pense
que l'écologie a évidemment un rôle à
jouer en ce sens alors c'est aussi un
sujet de volontarisme c'est aussi un
sujet temporalité et puis c'est aussi un
sujet de méthode
alors le volontarisme politique nous ne
manquons pas et ce sont ce sont
notamment les contreparties qui sont
demandées en échange des aides que ce
soit par le gouvernement ou par l'union
européenne il ya la question évidemment
de la temporalité il ya le court terme
avec le avec le plan de relance la
question de la baisse des impôts de
production c'est aussi un moyen de
soutenir la compétitivité et donc
l'emploi
et puis les jeunes démocrates dans leur
formidable petite vidéo parlait non
pardon c'était louis de redon qui
parlait rénovation rénovation
énergétique et thermique en mettant bien
en avant le fait que c'était justement
les plus les plus modestes qui en
général souffrait souffrait de cette
question est donc évidemment la
rénovation énergétique non seulement
elle fait des emplois non délocalisables
mais en plus elle va évidemment jouer en
faveur de de l'ecologie
et puis il ya évidemment des mesures à
plus long terme mais qui doivent se
prendre dès aujourd'hui alors
ça me permet de dire toute ma
satisfaction quant à la nomination d'un
haut commissaire au plan
d'autant plus quand on connaît le
titulaire de postes les qualités dont il
est doté doute pas que que ça ira tout à
fait dans le bon sens parce que la
transformation de l'appareil productif
l'innovation ça prend du temps et ça
demande des décisions aujourd'hui pour
les 5 10 15 20 prochaines années
et puis effectivement il faut pas hésité
non plus à questionner nos fondamentaux
en matière de modèle économique
je voudrais vous donner deux exemples le
premier exemple a trait au transport en
ile de france depuis vingt ans on se
satisfait de conditions absolument
déplorable pour les usagers mais ça
n'est qu'à ces conditions que le modèle
économique peut perdurer
eh bien ce n'est plus possible il faut
changer ça il n'est plus acceptable que
les transports en ile de france soit
dans cet état là et donc oui il faut
changer le modèle économique des
transports franciliens
autre exemple de la question du tourisme
la question du tourisme à paris l'année
dernière paris a accueilli 38 millions
de tourisme de touristes venant de du
monde entier c'est formidable ça montre
l'attractivité de la ville
mais on est aussi arrivé à un point qui
n'est plus soutenable à la fois pour les
touristes eux-mêmes mais aussi pour les
habitants et il faut profondément revoir
ce modèle du tourisme alors bien
évidemment on va pas le revoir en un
claquement de doigts bien évidemment il
va falloir accompagner les
professionnels
on ne va pas du jour au lendemain passer
d'un tourisme de masse un tourisme
durable que j'appelle de mes voeux mais
néanmoins c'est vers ce chemin là aussi
qu'il faut aller et puis troisième point
bon c'était elodie jacky laforge qui en
parlait dans la dans la vidéo réalisée
par les jeunes démocrates c'est aussi
évidemment la question de la
concertation n'avancera pas seul il faut
avancer avec les entreprises
bien évidemment on ne fera rien contre
elle bien évidemment il faut les pousser
au plus loin possible
se fixer des objectifs ambitieux mais
atteignable et puis aussi avancé avec
nos concitoyens
et puis des remerciements méthode
il ya le sujet des externalités
positives et négatives qu'on ne prend
pas en compte aujourd'hui dans les
critères de croissance et arrêtons de
considérer alors nous les moyens sont
des ressources limitées il faut
désormais les prendre en considération
je terminerai avec un sujet est
extrêmement qui touche au coeur de
richard ramos et la question de
l'alimentation
il ya le sujet de la souveraineté
alimentaire on a la chance d'avoir un
modèle agricole extrêmement riche
alors aujourd'hui n'est pas suffisant
pour être autosuffisants néanmoins il
faut évidemment qu'on puisse qu'on
puisse avancer vers les circuits courts
vers le développement du bio mais ça ça
demande de la prévisibilité de
l'anticipation de travailler main dans
la main de faire adhérer à la fois les
professionnels et les consommateurs mais
je suis sûr qu'avec un petit peu de
volonté on y arrivera je vous remercie
maximum merci merci à toi ya déjà
beaucoup de questions qui arrive sur la
boucle mais on va essayer de prendre nos
intervenants et on prendra les questions
après il ya vous êtes déjà assez
nombreux à poser des questions on va on
va continuer dans cette table ronde par
internet à ne toujours à toi
anneux on te connaît bien donc tu es
première adjointe au maire de louviers
présidente des deux airs elle qu'est la
régie de restauration de ta ville et
puis grande spécialiste aussi de on va
dire de l'énergie dans les bâtiments
dont cannes on va casser la parole pour
te demander c'est quoi ta vision j'ai
envie de dire ta vision de terrain et
puis euh tu as écris je crois que la
transition énergétique porte une
dimension érotique
alors je crois que c'était évidemment au
sens étymologique du mot érotique mais
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer ta
vision sur le sujet merci à toi
merci richard bonjour à toutes et à tous
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver même
sous forme numérique
oui c'est vrai alors c'est pas moi qui
l'ait dit que l'a dit que la transition
écologique porter une dimension érotique
mais patrick viveret qui est un
essayiste bien connu et bien sûr c'est
au sens étymologique du terme c'est à
dire que c est rose contre thanatos eros
le dieu grec
le dieu de l'amour le dieu de la
puissance créatrice et thanatos le dieu
de la mort donc bien sûr la trilogie
comporte une dimension hérétiques au
sens où il faut être acteur de cette
transition énergétique écologique qui
procède de cette volonté de vivre
indispensable qui nous permettra
d'inventer des nouvelles techniques des
nouvelles collaborations et des
nouvelles participation citoyenne et
bien sûr des nouveaux modèles
économiques des nouvelles manières de
faire
voilà c'était dans son sac mais je
trouve que la langue est intéressant de
parler de la transition écologique sous
cette forme de et érotique sous cette
forme de puissance de vie qui me semble
nécessaire aujourd'hui
alors moi ma conviction en fait ma
vision c'est que cette transition
écologique et maux de la rappeler
d'ailleurs à l'instant nourris et
renouvelle la démocratie et il me semble
que au regard de ce qu'on a vécu ces
derniers mois avoir ces dernières années
c'est peut-être ce dont on a le plus
besoin
mais en l'espèce la transition
énergétique a besoin en fait d'une
grande concertation citoyenne fin mai
pour une acceptation sociale sociétale
donc dans la gouvernance que on a à
mettre en place sur ces questions de
transition énergétique on a besoin de
l'ensemble des acteurs des acteurs
économiques mais on a aussi besoin du
financement participatif des citoyens
c'est la manière en fait d'exercer au
plus haut niveau sa citoyenneté et je
trouve moi que c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui je voudrais dire aussi que
le financement de la transition
énergétique puisque c'est je vais
peut-être abordé davantage cet angle est
possible et que d'une manière générale
le manque d'argent n'est pas opposable à
cette transition ce n'est pas ça n'est
pas vrai et ça n'est pas possible
d'opposer ce manque d'argent il existe
il faut se mobiliser alors ça va être
encore plus vrai aujourd'hui avec le
plan de relance du gouvernement français
mais également celui de l'union
européenne
donc l'argent existe il faut pouvoir le
mobiliser il faut pour cela un certain
nombre d'ingrédients notamment la
volonté politique bien sûr il faut faire
le constat avoir envie de faire avancer
son territoire il faut de l'ingéniérie
parce que c'est vrai que ça s'improvise
pas non plus cette question de
transition énergétique
il faut de l'ingéniosité et l'agilité et
puis il faut être capable de mener ces
partenariats multiples dont je parlais
et puisque je crois avec beaucoup de
force mais on l'a vu dans le d'ailleurs
dans le petit reportage des jdem c'est
que la transition énergétique rapport de
l'argent et créer de l'emploi
c'est vrai c'est c'est ce que moi je
constate en permanence sur mon
territoire
je peux peut-être vous parler de
quelques quelques expériences locales en
fait nous portons nous sur notre
territoire puisque j'ai en fait j'ai la
responsabilité de l'élaboration du plan
climat air énergie territoire qui est un
document aujourd'hui obligatoire pour
nous nos établissements de coopération
intercommunale qui est un document
stratégique qui d'ailleurs celui avec
les autres documents stratégiques de
notre collectivité mais et qui permet de
mettre en oeuvre cette stratégie énergie
climat et donc on a plusieurs projets il
y en a qui sont enfin certaines choses
sont déjà réalisés et notamment la
maison de l'habitat qui est aujourd'hui
un dispositif que nous portons et qui
est un guichet unique pour toutes les
personnes qui ont un projet de
rénovation de leur habitat
l'objectif c'est bien sûr la lutte
contre la précarité énergétique et dans
le film leur petit reportage qu'on a vu
précédemment
louis de redon en parler ce qui est bon
pour la planète est aussi bon pour notre
porte-monnaie et notamment pour celui
d'aider les plus défavorisés
donc voilà la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique et la promotion de la
sobriété le maintien à domicile des
seniors qui en prend aussi très
important la lutte contre la vacance et
contre l'habitat dégradé aujourd'hui sur
notre territoire
alors bien sûr nous convention avec
l'anah kehl agence nationale pour
l'amélioration de l'habitat et le
chiffre d'affaires qui est générée pour
les entreprises parce que qui dit
rénovation dix entreprises btp en
général c'est des entreprises du
territoire
et bien c'est à peu près c'est un peu
plus de 2 millions d'euros en fait de
travaux qui re qui sont en partie
mentionné en tout cas co financé à la
fois par l'agglomération et par la
meilleure par l'anah et qui reviennent
bien sûr à nos entreprises du territoire
alors 2 millions ça peut paraître rien
n'est en réalité je pense que pour ces
entreprises et pme et c'est tpe c'est
important et ce dispositif qui n'a que
deux ans et mon temps en charge
aujourd'hui et donc on a globalement une
croissance due de la mobilisation des
dispositifs de 30% par an donc on voit
bien qu attend
qu'est-ce qu'il va parce qu'il reste
donc aux candidats à fait mauvais donc à
terme
voilà ça va être encore plus d'argent
pour nos entreprises n'est peut-être
aussi la régie dre parlé un petit peu de
la régie de restauration si c'est
possible richard si tu me parles
alimentation je dois donner une minute
supplémentaire
bon alors la régie de restauration j'en
parle parce que c'est hyper important
aussi pour moi donc c'est un outil
industriel qui est tout à fait novateur
que je vous invite à visiter quand vous
voulez sur le territoire de louviers et
on avait des marchés grâce à cet outil
on avait eu on avait commencé la
démarche qui maintenant est inscrite
dans la loi et galim aujourd'hui on est
à environ 60% de local dont 22 % de bio
donc on va atteindre les objectifs sans
difficulté ce qui est un très très
intéressant c'est de voir la dynamique
qui est tout autour
puisqu'en fait l'agglomération à une
politique d'acquisitions foncières de
terres agricoles qui sont aujourd'hui
loulou est en fait à des maraîchers bio
ce qui nous permet du coup
en fait nous ont créé la demande puisque
on a donc d'ici quelques semaines 1600
repas/jour fournit essentiellement pour
les cantines scolaires mais également
pour les résidences autonomie et donc
nous créons l'inde du bio ou du local
qui est très importante et est donc il
va falloir organiser l'offre et
l'ensemble de la filière or nous sommes
sur un territoire maraîchers puisque la
scène n'est pas très loin et entre la
demande que présente en fait la
métropole de rouen avec la même démarche
que la nôtre est la nôtre on voit bien
qu'il ya des centaines d'hectares et
peut-être plus maintenant à aménager à
convertir en bio il faudra accompagner
cette transition et c'est ce à quoi nous
nous employons voilà donc globalement on
a des exploitations qui devrait revenir
sur le territoire pour du maraîchage
convention fin du maraîchage locales et
du maraîchage local et bio et tout ça et
créateurs non seulement d'emplois mais
de recherche de richesse et peut-être
juste pour finir me disais qu'il fallait
peut-être pousser les entreprises mois
dans l'élaboration du programme du pca
ut
bien sûr on interroge les entreprises et
ce que je constate et on est un terrain
est un territoire d'industrie sur ses
nerfs ce que je constate c'est qu'elles
sont très demandeuses
ces entreprises elles veulent prendre
leur part elles veulent participer et
elles savent très bien que ce qui est
bon pour la planète est bon aussi pour
leurs économies pour leur modèle
économique et donc on a plein de projets
l'économie circulaire et de production
des réseaux de chaleur des productions
d'énergies renouvelables avec elle voilà
je vous remercie
merci encore merci à beaucoup de
questions qu arrive on va les prendre
tout à l'heure on termine avec nos
intervenants on va écouter notre ami
sylvain waserman donc silva député modem
d'alsace sylvain tut tut a édité un
livre qui s'appelle le monde d'après
commence demain matin tu as également
sur ton territoire participé à beaucoup
de choses autour de l'emploi notamment
de le coaching de jeunes en recherche
d'emploi
on voulait entendre sylvain sûr
évidemment quelle est ta vision de
développement durable qui met l'homme au
coeur de j'ai envie de dire du village
et puis le développement économique donc
je vais te laisser la parole si la merci
beaucoup richard bonjour à toutes et à
tous de participer à cette table ronde
j'aimerais peut-être commencer par
insisté sur le fait que dans cette
sortie de crise à la fois le
développement économique et le
développement durable qui sont vraiment
au coeur des enjeux qu'on a relevé
aujourd'hui ces deux enjeux sont des
compétences régionales et je trouve que
dans le débat public
on n'insiste pas assez sur le fait que
tout cela fonctionnera ou pas en
fonction de la du succès de
l'articulation entre élections
nationales élections régionales les
secondes territoriale et finalement
cette crise à la porte ou cette sortie
de crise les gens enjeux de cette sortie
de crise elle apporte donc un regard
complètement différent sur la place des
territoires et sur les façons de réussir
que soit le plan de relance qui en lui
même est excellent mais qu'une réussira
que si les territoires sont en part et
aussi sur la croissance verte donc les
enjeux du développement durable qui là
aussi sont une compétence des régions et
des territoires
et je crois que c'est une pensée
importante de se dire que finalement le
succès ou l'échec de cette sortie de
crise qu vide et et de ce qu'on est en
train de reconstruire
ça dépendra fondamentalement des
territoires je vais prendre deux
exemples
effectivement dans l' ouvrage que j'ai
que j'ai publié il ya il ya deux
semaines il ya quarante propositions
concrètes et mon parti pris c'est de
dire que finalement sur des thématiques
très territorialisée comme cela on a des
compétences et on a des outils et
finalement on pèche un peu sur les deux
donc je vais simplement formulé deux
propositions un peu iconoclaste mais que
je soumets à votre à votre réflexion
pour essayer d'accélérer cette reprise
de la croissance la première sur le
développement économique et sur l'emploi
on connaît tous l'importance marguerite
en a parlé l'importance les enjeux qu'on
va avoir sur chacun de nos territoires
sur l'emploi et bien moi je crois qu'il
est temps alors sans de développer trop
il est temps de franchir le pas et de
décentraliser pôle emploi en tout cas la
fonction opérationnelle de pôle emploi
celle qui vise à rapprocher l'offre de
la demande et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les élus régionaux les collectivités
régionales avec leur proximité en étant
directement en prise avec les
entreprises est plus à même de réussir
cette adéquation qui est un facteur clé
de succès pour la reprise et pour
l'emploi entre les demandeurs d'emploi
et les entreprises
donc je pense qu'il est temps
d'expérimenter on a une loi 3d qui
arrive bientôt
c'est une idée qui flotte depuis un
certain temps je pense qu'ils aient le
temps d'être un peu audacieux et
d'expérimenter dans une région ce
transfert de compétences en transférant
pour l'emploi à aux régions
la deuxième proposition que j'ai affaire
concerne la transition énergétique alors
j'avais écrit un livre blanc qui
expliquait que notre transition
énergétique
elle ne peut se faire sans les
territoires et que finalement elle sera
territoriale où elle ne sera tout
simplement pas et quand on voit des
modèles très décentralisée comme
l'allemagne
ils sont très en avance sur le taux de
production d'énergie renouvelable
ils ont d'autres problèmes enfin sur ce
point là ils sont très en avance sur
nous est l'une des raisons c'est que
finalement on a beau définir des tarifs
de rachat à paris et définir des grands
enjeux à paris c'est très bien il faut
le faire il faut le cadre national
mais finalement est-ce qu'un porteur de
projet va saisir d'un projet de
biométhane ou d'éoliennes et ce qui va
le mener à bien et ce qu'avec les sur le
sur le territoire il arrivera à passer
obstacle par obstacles et bien c'est
finalement ça qui fait le succès ou
l'échec de la transition énergétique
c'est l'émergence ou pas de ces deux ses
projets et leur succès ou pas qui des
phoques qui dépend très largement des
logiques territoriales sur sa là aussi
on devrait prendre des décisions
courageuses comme par exemple celle de
confier aux régions la possibilité de
faire les arbitrages sur les tarifs de
rachat pour avoir des politiques
beaucoup plus différenciés pour avoir
dans une région par exemple comme
l'anneau dans le grand est
on est une région très agricole on a
beaucoup de déchets agricoles on a
beaucoup de projets sur le biométhane et
bien les élus pourraient dire et on met
le paquet sur les tarifs de rachat sur
le biométhane est sûre je sais pas sur
la géothermie profonde par exemple et et
moins sur le solaire ou sur autre bref
essayer de différencier les politiques
de de développement durable et de
production d'éoliennes et de transition
énergétique et enfin j'aurais peut-être
conclure alors j'ai quatre ou cinq
minutes je vais juste conclure oui
puisque deux minutes par la notion d'
outil on a un plan de relance qui est
extrêmement volontariste des régions qui
comme je le disais doivent être à la
hauteur pour se saisir de ces
opportunités elle est transcendé réalité
au manque encore cruellement d'outils et
les textes empêche par exemple les
régions de lancer des fonds souverains
régionaux l'idée du fonds souverain
régional oui je m'arrête mari de maths
l'idée du fonds souverain régionales
c'est quelque chose qui permettrait aux
élus d'investir et d'accompagner les
entreprises pour l'économie verte et
c'est l'exemple de des législations qui
doivent s'assouplir pour donner plus de
marge aux territoires
merci beaucoup merde merci à toi silva
yassa encore remis des questions donc on
va pouvoir y répondre bientôt bientôt
bientôt on va prendre dans cette belle
table ronde notre dernière intervenant
notre ambassadeur et donc merci a toi
yann d'être présent avec nous yan tu
voulais je pense que nous parler d'un
rapport qui vient de sortir
du centre d'analysé économique sur un
sujet qui tient à coeur la biodiversité
donc il ya je vais tester la parole et
puis bien évidemment après yade on
pourra répondre à l'ensemble des
questions qui n'ont pas manqué de
d'arriver sur le le fil des questions
merci à vous merci à toi yann et je te
laisse la parole
amandine ça capte plus chez moi
alors est ce que c'est moi ou est-ce que
c'est yann qui ne capte
pas j'ai fait une bêtise et cruel ces
recrutements étaient coupées en fait
j'ai tout simplement appuyé sur accroché
je suis vraiment désolé non c'est bon je
m'entendais aux plaisirs du coup bon
merci merci merci enfin bonjour hamoud
bonjour à à anna silva et à tous les
hommes tous les autres tous les autres
intervenants enfin toutes les personnes
qui sont connectés je suis et puis
marguerite pardon excusez moi je suis
très content avec voulu rencontrer
frustré de pas ne pas vous toucher
c'est très frustrant tout ça c'est
depuis des mois on fait des choses comme
ça ils matériel et je trouve que on
oublie un petit peu qu'on ait quand même
des êtres sociaux mais on va faire avec
et je crois qu'on sait civique de
procéder de cette manière là fectivement
merci richard de m'avoir proposé de
parler sur ce ton la biodiversité parce
que c'est pas seul bon le sujet que je
que je suis depuis des années c'est
aussi maintenant assuré nick c'est un
peu le pape prend pauvres des questions
environnementales à chaque fois qu'on
parle des problèmes de planète à tous
les échelons on n'a que le mot climat
qui vient à nos oreilles on oublie qu'il
ya un autre phénomène extrêmement grave
j'allais dire peut-être presque plus
vite talent encore que le changement de
température et du climat même si c'est
difficile de faire des hiérarchies
mais c'est la question de l'état de la
nature la biodiversité qui nous entoure
juste pour rappel parce que enfin pour
moi c'est un rappel pour beaucoup
d'entre eux peut-être que ça ne le sera
malheureusement pas mais la situation
est extrêmement grave au cours des
quarante cinquante dernières années nous
avons à peu près détruite hier du monde
sauvage tout simplement ça peut paraître
fou mais mais c'est à peu près ce qui c
40 50 dernières années les deux tiers du
monde sauvage c'est à dire qu'il ya à
aujourd'hui
vous prenez vous mettez dans un pot
commun tout ce qui a deux mammifères de
reptiles d'oiseaux et bien il ya il ya 5
% de cette masse là ce sont des animaux
sauvages
ce lourd sans le reste c'est pour 65% du
reste c'est les animaux de compagnie nos
animaux d'élevage les boeufs les cochons
les poules
tout ce que nous élevons et puis tous
nos chiens et nos chats ça constitue 60
5% de la masse vivante de biomasse
existantes sur terre aujourd'hui et les
35% restants
c'est c'est nous les êtres humains donc
si c'est vous montrer à quel point nous
occupons aujourd'hui une place
absolument considérable sur la planète
et surtout la place réduite que nous
avons laissé au monde sauvage alors il y
en a certains qui diront so what
quel est le problème le problème il est
que bien évidemment il ya un problème
moral mais allez on va dire que des fois
ça peut aussi être un sujet secondaire
pour beaucoup les questions morales et
que c'est pas ça doit pas entrer en
ligne de compte dans la politique dont
je vais vous parler d'économie c'est un
problème économique aujourd'hui la
disparition de la biodiversité
on n'arrive pas encore tout à fait à
mesurer mais je crains malheureusement
qu'il ne faille pas attendre de pouvoir
le mesurer les impacts économiques de
cet effondrement de la biodiversité
d'abord c'est des impacts évidemment en
termes de 2,2 capacité à pouvoir
continuer à produire de la nourriture en
quantité en quantité suffisante pour me
relancer
on doit lutter chaque fois que ont
réduit la biodiversité on augmente la
câble à la les dangers qui pèsent sur
sur la capacité de produire des aliments
parce qu'il ya deux maladies qui
affectent les plantes et à la diversité
biologique est un rempart aux maladies
en réalité c'est l'appauvrissement de la
diversité biologique est un qui est un
facteur d'accroissement à 10 dans les
plantes et donc on a toujours besoin de
toujours plus de d'intrants pour pouvoir
réduire ces maladies or évidemment ça
c'est de plus en plus coûteux pouvoir
produire de l'alimentation en
particulier de la réduction de la
biodiversité la réduction de la
biodiversité c'est aussi évidemment
les impacts sur les le cycle de l'eau le
cycle de l'eau aujourd'hui est parlé par
les atteintes à l'environnement par
toutes nos infrastructures
évidemment ça crée des phénomènes à la
fois des inondations dans certains cas
et de sécheresse avec excessif dans
d'autres donc c'est évidemment un vrai
gros problème je vous ai pas tous les
problèmes aujourd'hui qui sont liées à
la médecine et à la santé on est
quasiment certain lui que toutes les
études scientifiques convergent vers
cela que l'aco vide a pour raison d'être
noski elle même ces zoonoses là qui
émergent sont de plus en plus nombreuses
et ont pour aux raisons ayant pour cause
les atteintes à la biodiversité
je vous fais pas laisser le schéma mais
évidemment que les impacts économiques
aujourd'hui de l'acolyte sont absolument
considérable et que d'autres atteintes à
la biodiversité faire émettre et créer
de nouvelles zones aux auront des
impacts économie absolument à quoi donc
il ya beaucoup de services aujourd'hui
que la biodiversité rang de manière
totalement gratuite 1 le filtrage ou la
lutte contre les maladies sans qu'on
s'en rende compte
le capacité de résorber les impacts
naturel tout ceci c'est une réalité
donc je crois que aujourd'hui il est
temps qu'on réagisse il est temps que
l'on construit donc ce petit système de
court terme dans lequel on est où l'on
considère jamais qu'il est grave
d'atteindre et de dégrader la
biodiversité qu'on pourra tout régler le
problème plus tard notamment avec de la
science avec la technologie est une
erreur très grave et que la biodiversité
on va dire à la différence de beaucoup
d'autres phénomènes auxquels la rue eh
bien on ne la fait pas revenir c'est
c'est un dommage irréversible
donc là parce qu'on a ce qu'ont souhaité
qu'on bouge alors aujourd'hui je note
aussi qu'il ya une relation vivant qui a
changé chez les français dont beaucoup
d'opinions publiques
cette relation au vigan fait que
aujourd'hui à une science grandissante
que je ne peux que constater comme vous
dans la population
cette force qui fait que quand ce
sondage après sondage en voile que les
deux tiers de la population attentes des
pouvoirs publics et des réactions
rapides assez situation environnementale
gravissime
une petite partie j'allais dire de la
population regroupée dans des lobbys
réussi à un pc public de se prendre en
pêche la décision politique de se
prendre et moi ce que je pars en janvier
politiquement je finirai là dessus
peut-être qu'on pourra développer sur
les questions c'est une radicalisation
c'est une radicalisation entre d'un côté
des mouvements populaires qui
s'impatiente de plus en plus et qui
verse dans la radicalité ce qui n'est
pas le fond de le fond de notre famille
politique et d'un autre que des lobbys
qu ils sont tout aussi radicaux qui
refuse habituellement toute évolution et
qui je ne sais par quel mystère
réussissent à bloquer la décision
politique a au plus haut niveau donc je
moi j'en appelle à ce que de notre
famille politique
et bien finalement reprenne à son compte
ce qu'elle a toujours su faire de mieux
c'est à dire construire des minables
être la force politique de la modération
qui invite aux radicaux 2 à se parler ou
en tout cas c'est une belle passe par
les affaires des propositions de 2,2
d'évolution et d'avancer sont pas qu un
bien au contraire cessé de gravir un
échelon dans la protection de la
biodynamie sûr merci merci merci merci
yann beaucoup de questions donc on va on
va prendre une série de questions est ce
que évidemment les invités de cette
table ronde répondront comme ils le
veulent à aux questions je vais en
prendre une peu une première série
bonjour qu'en est il du principe
pollueur payeur
voilà pour la première question
deuxième question alors de jean luc
perron pourquoi le bio est-il trois fois
plus cher dans le panier du consommateur
final
en faisant ainsi une denrée de luxe des
produits bio autre question de le
tanneur allô bonjour qu'en est il du
principe pollueur payeur
voilà encore quelques questions qui ont
été posées un commentaire de béatrice du
trio développement du bio bien sûr mais
faire en sorte que lorsqu'on ne peut pas
acheter du bio les produits soient
néanmoins de qualité toute personne
quelle que soit sa situation financière
doit pouvoir accéder à des aliments à
une alimentation saine
peut-être également une autre question
quid de l'agriculture hors sol est ce
une solution à court terme pour manque
pour une orestie demande également qui
nous et qui nous est posée alors on le
voit bien dans ses premières questions
autour de l'alimentation est ce que vous
pouvez essayer de commencer à répondre à
cette première série de questions merci
à vous
alors peut-être une sur également bar
dont une dernière qui vient d'arriver
sur la rénovation énergétique posée par
pierre cohen ce la rénovation
énergétique est essentielle mais comment
sera fait la priorisation des chantiers
comment doit-on réagir à l'échelon
municipal départemental régional
national et surtout quand doit-on le
faire est-ce que vous pouvez essayer
pour les uns et les autres d'essayer de
répondre à cette première série de
questions type qui veut commencer à
répondre
répondre quelques éléments alors je
bonne spécialiste de l'agriculture mais
ce que je peux faire ce que je vois moi
c'est l'utilisation des produits locaux
et bio d'ailleurs en fait je peux pas
être dogmatique sur le sujet il faut
surtout pas opposer les uns aux autres
sur notre territoire on a des
agriculteurs en bio et des agriculteurs
en conventionnel est certain qu'ils
essayent de de se rapprocher du bio mais
qui n'ont pas encore pu financièrement
fin dans le modèle économique prendre
les trois années où quasiment les trois
années de mise en sommeil de leurs
terres pour passer être labellisé en bio
ce que je constate néanmoins c'est que
c'est vrai que les produits bio sont un
peu plus chers indéniablement c'est le
cas en même temps nous on l'est on va
les chercher directement auprès du
producteur
donc évidemment on a pas d'intermédiaire
donc j'imagine que ça limite
probablement la hausse du prix mais ce
que je constate c'est que leur qualité
permet de faire mieux en achetant moins
est en tout cas le la réalité sur la rue
c'est une régie de restauration donc je
voulais 10600 couverts jour ce qui la
réalité c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui en
faisant en ayant cette démarche qui
d'ailleurs en fait me permet aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs mutualiser et l'outil de
production avec d'autres communes et on
a un cadre juridique de mutualisation
horizontale on n'a pas ce qui veut dire
qu'on n'a pas transféré la compétence à
l'agglo mais que dans le schéma de
mutualisation de l'agglo les communes
s'engagent à utiliser le même outil au
profit de leurs clients de leurs
bénéficiaires et bienfaisance a en fait
on à diminuer le coût du repas faire qu
en augmentant le local et le bio
d'hommes dans les ingrédients de marchés
de matières premières
on est on a de façon très significative
diminuer le coût de production du repas
alors évidemment ça nécessite une autre
manière de cuisiner ça n'est
probablement possible que parce que on a
un outil de production qui est très
novateur avec une marche en avant et
c'est ça serait sûrement pas possible
dans une cuisine un peu traditionnelle
et puis parce qu'on a le savoir faire
s'est il ya une équipe formidable donc
ce que je constate c'est que oui
le kilo de tomates bio coûtent plus cher
que le kilo de tomates classique mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi regarder au
global sa production impact -
l'environnement
il ya moins de coûts de transport et
puis je moi je constate que par un
mécanisme assez complexe on arrive à
faire baisser le prix du repas
donc ça c'est intéressant sur la
question de la transition d'un bâtiment
de la ddt et bâtiments publics et privés
et de la sobriété énergétique
je crois qu'ils je sais pas s'il faut
dire qu'en commencer par quoi commencer
comment on priorise ce que je peux dire
peut-être c'est un peu la méthode qu'on
a utilisées on sait qu'il faut que tous
les acteurs s'y mettent
les les propriétaires bailleurs les
propriétaires occupants les les
bailleurs sociaux les bailleurs sociaux
en particulier qui ont évidemment des
gros collectif et puis les entreprises
et puis les collectivités qui sont elles
mêmes
détentrices d'un patrimoine public
souvent assez important en fait je pense
que ce qu'il faut faire c'est que toute
construction nouvelle soit bien sûr au
moins aux normes en vigueur mais si
possible plutôt bepos et qu'il faut bien
sûr visé enfin si on veut améliorer la
performance énergétique de nos bâtiments
et surtout notre bilan carbone parce que
c'est de ça dont il s'agit
il faut viser évidemment les effets
leviers donc assez facilement maintenant
avec des bureaux d'études dans nos
documents de planification on est
capable de cibler les bâtiments ou les
quartiers qui seront très amateur et
donc c'est évidemment là il faut avoir
une démarche proactive avec tous les
outils qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
disposition et c'est comme ça qu'on ya
évidemment les gros bassins industriels
syndicats c'est le cas des bailleurs
sociaux
c'est le cas aussi à l'eau les réponses
courtes s'il vous plaît on refait pas le
débat plutôt des réponses courtes aux
gens qui mourront
je prends une question peut-être une
pour mode
dans les interrogations qui sont celles
de nos deux de nos sympathisants une
revient souvent est ce que on assiste
finalement à une dualité entre la
ruralité et finalement une minorité bobo
peut-être plus populiste que populaires
comme disait yann qui voudraient
apprendre imposer une pensée aux autres
et toi qui es parisienne on a vu
beaucoup de si je résume la pensée de
certains on a vu beaucoup durba essayé
dicter une forme de pensée unique
minoritaire mais un peu violente
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
comment toi tu imagines finalement des
bassins de vie comme le tien qui vont
énormément consommateurs parce qu'on se
rassure la métropolisation sans que ça
soit au détriment de la ruralité comment
tu tu envisages ces deux schémas de
pensée qui semble aujourd'hui s'opposer
mode
alors le côté donneur de leçons des
parisiens jeu j'aimerais j'aimerais m'y
opposer mais je crains malheureusement
que ce soit un peu la réalité jeu à
nouveau à mon sens c'est c'est ensemble
qu'on fait avancer les choses justes sur
la question du bio c'est trois fois plus
cher en général parce que par définition
c'est plus fragiles
il ya plus il ya plus de jeux de fruits
ou de légumes sont jetés et donc ça a un
impact sur le prix mais pour moi le bio
il doit pas être l'alpha et l'oméga de
notre nouvelle manière du mieux manger
une poire argentine hors saison bio ça
n'a aucun intérêt
ce qui compte c'est du bio ou une
filière dont on laisse le temps de
grandir progressivement bien encadré
c'est ce sont les circuits courts c'est
cet écosystème l'acquis qui existe
depuis très longtemps
or paris mais que les parisiens ont
commencé à découvrir et tant mieux et je
pense que c'est ensemble qu'on
réfléchira à la meilleure manière de se
nourrir alors ça passe aussi évidemment
par l'éducation au goût mais mais
également de faire de notre agriculture
un encore un plus grand atout
qu'aujourd'hui et donc si les parisiens
auront cette tendance à agacer tout le
monde
servons nous deux pour faire en sorte de
faire avancer tous ces sujets et puis je
voulais juste revenir sur le sujet le
principe pollueur payeur
c'était c'était ce que je soulignais
tout à l'heure avec le sujet des biens
communs encore une fois le principe
pollueur payeur exister tant mieux mais
il faut aller au delà il ya le sujet de
l'eau de l'air et il faut tenir compte
de toutes ces externalités qu'elles
soient positives ou négatives dans la
manière de produire et on le fait pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui je prends
plusieurs questions que j'ai regroupé un
peu la question de valve trop et ce
n'est on oppose réponse scientifique un
changement de comportement personnel et
donc comment les uns et les autres
penser qu'on va faire vivre à la fois où
la nouvelle technologie la science qui
doit répondre à certains types de
problématiques et le changement
personnel et donc comment vous vous
imaginez ça c'est à dire est ce que
finalement il faut attendre toute la
science elle répondra aux au problème
thématique c'est à dire on inventera des
plans qui résisteront au climat au
stress hydrique etc
ou est-ce que tout doit être dans le
comportement ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
équilibre entre les deux mais en tout
cas ce que quelqu'un peut échanger sur
technologie j'ai envie de dire science
et puis finalement le comportement
individuel de chacun ou comme dirait
pierre rabhi chacun prend sa part
sylvain oui merci beaucoup
j'ai peut-être de réflexion sur le sujet
et qui rejoignent un peu ce qui a été
dit précédemment
d'abord le progrès scientifique c'est un
processus continu donc ya pas un moment
où la situation s'arrête et puis tout
est réglé cessé depuis le début d'été
but d'humaniser un processus continu
donc continuellement on à s'adapter à
cela continuellement on a trouvé le bon
équilibre entre les choix technologiques
entre le progrès est entre nos
comportements individuels mais
j'aimerais du coup rebondir sur une des
choses qui a été dit précédemment par
exemple sur le bio et je crois que c'est
un point important c'est qu'aujourd'hui
en réalité on n'a pas donné assez de
cadres pour pour permettre les
comportements de ceux de les
comportements individuels de se déployer
pleinement comme avec conscience
citoyenne j'ai un exemple tout simple
moi j'étais toujours choqué à avant
d'être député et heureusement qu'on l'a
résolu à partir de janvier prochain
le miel que tu achètes est un miel où il
ya marqué c'est dans ton magasins u et
non lieu qui peut dire qui peut cacher
la vérité que 60% du maître du miel et
un mail chinois fabriqués en usine
bah non il faut dire que dans ce cas-là
60% sur l'étiquette il faut mettre que
60% c'est du miel chinois fabriqués en
chine jeudi fabriquer parce que c'est
souvent dans des usines à sucre plus que
dans 2 que que dans des ruches qui va
pareil sur le bio le bio je me souviens
en alliant était maire quand j'ai
commencé mon mandat il ya c'était il ya
dix ans j'avais demandé de trouver des
offres avec repas bio et ben je ne
trouvais pas de repas 100% bio pour
pouvoir le faire deux fois par semaine
aujourd'hui on a voté une loi qui
s'appelle et galim qui à partir de 2022
donnera des obligations en matière donc
moi je crois que sur ces sujets de
comportement individuel il faut
s'adresser à l'intelligence du
consommateur et des citoyens et que si
tu revenais si tu avais un étiquetage
par exemple sur l'impact climatique de
ce que tu achètes 2 à 1
comme tu l'as pour pour l'habitat
machines à laver et que à la fin de ton
ticket de caisse tu pouvais voir que 80%
de ces achats étaient à hulu belux eh eh
ben on s'adresserait à l'intelligence
des consommateurs à l'intelligence des
citoyens et on ferait progresser on leur
donnerait les moyens de faire progresser
la cause
très bien merci sylvain je rappelle
simplement que dans la loi sur
l'étiquetage par votre serviteur on a
fait passer ce texte doit qui permet de
donner les origines du miel notamment
également pour ce qu'achète du chocolat
les origines du chocolat et donc grâce
au modem on pourra à partir du 1er
janvier dans les supermarchés regarder
les origines du miel est également les
origines du chocolat peut-être une
question pour yann il ya une question
d'agnès jeauneau adsl elle te demande
yat-il unanimité parmi les scientifiques
en ce qui concerne la biodiversité et
donc que voilà est-ce que est ce que
tous les scientifiques s'accordent à
dire que il ya une urgence de la
biodiversité ou finalement comme
certains finalement c'est pas si grave
que ça est ce que tu peux répondre diam
est ce que yann à yann est déconnecté
donc il
aura pas répondre à cette question je
voudrais également d'autres questions
qui sont qui sont sur l'emploi
marguerite
on voudrait aussi dans toi dans une
région qui est très touché par par la
crise de l'emploi
comment comment tu penses que on peut
essayer de retrouver je dirais
localement est ce que l'économie locale
la green economy
est-ce que videmment vers chez toi ça
peut être un processus vers plus
d'emploi avoir le plein emploi comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que chez nous
c'est l'industrie qui est prédominante
mais la préoccupation de l'écologie
n'est pas un récent par l'économie
industrielle tout le monde un monde
industriel on communique très peu ou
très mal et donc on fait pas savoir que
tout ce qu'on fait mais il ya des
réglementations les normes
environnementales et parfois abusivement
contraignantes sont vraiment de rigueur
il ya toutes nos entreprises seront
certifiées iso 14000 par exemple donc
moi je voudrais qu'on passe de
l'industrie bashing à l'industrie aux
vignes passant sans industrie on
n'arrivera pas à sauver les emplois et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement on est aussi
persuadé qu'on veut relocaliser et puis
dans la région au de france par exemple
on a mis en route la troisième
révolution industrielle qui était lancée
il ya presque dix ans et qui partis du
principe de l'écologie serait sous des
papas économique donc que dans les
autres france on a plutôt une longueur
d'avancé
il ya aussi le le circulaire si je
prends ma mon métier les arts graphiques
c'est très longtemps qu'on on recycle
tout ce qu'on utilise
franchement en sites propres retomber
dans une industrie graphique et le
papier lui même et réutiliser les
recycle des mesures actuellement
l'assemblée fait partie d'un groupe de
travail sur le recyclage du papier ça ça
va que source outil de création
d'emplois donc je pense qu'avec la
transition écologique est ce ça et c'est
ces attitudes vertueuses que qu'à votre
cas adopter l'industrie on arrive à
créer des emplois et la sauvegarde et
nous emploient marguerite marguerite
marguerite est ce que tu peux nous nous
rappeler combien on consomme d'énergie
on envoie un mail par rapport à une
ramette de papier et pas entendre ça est
ce que tu peux nous rappeler quand
j'envoie un mail et les mac consommation
d'énergie quand je le compare à une
feuille papier
de mémoire c'est 150 feuilles de papier
c'est ça c'est 150 feuilles de papier et
comme je sais que tu aimes le papier tu
viens du monde dans la catégorie
ouah c'est voilà de l'énergie et aux
matières naturelles s'est fait parti du
président dubois morceaux nobles sont
réservés aux bugs mais les résidus sans
fond reste servent à faire de la pâte à
papier et le papier se recycle 6 x 2 stv
donc c'est tout à fait naturel
donc je milite tout pour le papier
j'adhère à l'association culture papier
parce que je trouve que voilà c'est
quelque chose aussi qu'on ne sait pas
c'est que nous comptons serveurs
informatiques vous plus consommateurs et
aussi pour la planète une bobine de
papier
et puis on rappellera que de temps en
temps quand on gère correctement une
forêt les jeunes arbres captent plus de
carbone que les anciens il faut une
action durable
et puis commandé un peu entre nous on
ira au maire de lyon caddie qui aurait
plus de bois mort sur lyon eh bien je me
demande moi comment il va faire ses
toilettes sèches
je reviens vers toi yam
il ya une question yann sur la science
finalement et la biodiversité
est ce que tous les scientifiques sont
d'accord sur le sujet et comment toi tu
imagines aujourd'hui un chemin pour
retrouver finalement une plus grande de
équilibre entre le développement naturel
de l'être humain et notre biodiversité
est ce que tu peux nous parler de la
science et des scientifiques par rapport
à la biodiversité les controverses
éventuelles et puis de savoir comment
toi tu imagines que toi même yann dans
tes réflexions et nous mouvement
démocrate
on peut trouver un chemin pour retrouver
des équilibres dans la biodiversité
merci merci richard c'est une question
tout à l'heure sur science versus
comportement j'allais dire versus
règlement aussi parce que il ya les
scientifiques qui a les comportements
individuels et puis à les comportements
collectifs le comportement collectif
c'est la décision publique c'est la
décision politique c'est quand même
trois piliers absolument indispensable
la science est là pour déconner science
ça aujourd'hui dans le domaine du climat
par exemple vous avez vu qu'il ya quand
même 90% aujourd'hui de la sphère
scientifique qui est d'accord et du côté
de la biodiversité les scientifiques de
la biodiversité c'est quasiment
l'unanimité pour dire qu'aujourd'hui on
traverse quasiment ce qu'on appelle une
sixième extinction des espèces due cette
fois ci à une seule espèce qui est
l'homme par l'être humain
donc oui la science est unanime après la
science est aussi effectivement des
solutions mais moi je veux vraiment
vraiment dire attention à ce discours
ambiant que j'entends qui est de se
réfugier derrière la science comme ceux
comme un facteur de solutions qui en
fait un prétexte pour ne rien faire et
pour ne pas agir à la fois sur le
comportement individuel et sur le
comportement collectif
c'est vrai pour le climat comme pour la
biodiversité donc cesser il faut pas
tout attendre de la science et surtout
elle ne peut pas tout résoudre ces cdd
philosophie du siècle dernier de penser
que toutes les solutions et en relation
c'est qu'en attendant on peut continuer
à faire n'importe quoi donc vraiment je
je j'appelle à faire attention à ces ce
dogme scientiste là qui est en train de
renaître de la part d'un certain nombre
de responsables politiques et
économiques et et je voulais revenir sur
sur un point qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est sûr le tout ce qui est
humain interpelle là dessus au richard
et qu'elles sont la suite les suites des
choses moi je crois qu'il ya à la fois
dans les comportements individuels faut
quand même se rendre compte qu'un
français aujourd'hui après 2,5 fois trop
si je veux dire si je veut simplifier on
mange trop 2005 planète pour satisfaire
nos besoins individuels donc
réfléchissez à ça regardez ya des
logiciels sur internet qui vous
permettent de calculer quelle serait
votre consommation
raisonnable si vous vouliez ne pas
consommer trop qui valent en de
ressources planétaires en biodiversité
en climent tout ce que vous voulez
divisé par deux et demi c'est énorme
mais c'est faisable
c'est absolument faisable et ça ne
change pas la qualité de vie au
quotidien c'est ce notamment par exemple
manger moins de viande
vous réduirez énormément autres
consommations d'équivalent planète
individuellement qui en termes de
comptes de comportements collectifs
moi je voudrais adresser un message
aussi est ce que j'entends souvent dire
que notamment sur la biodiversité c'est
une réalité
un des facteurs les plus aggravant les
plus difficiles pour la biodiversité
c'est l'agriculture aujourd'hui dans le
monde
c'est ça qui affecte le plus là la
biodiversité parce qu'on a des méthodes
d'agriculture extrêmement agressive est
ce que je veux dire moi c'est que j'en
ai un peu assez que à chaque fois que
quelqu'un comme moi comme d'autres ont
dit qu'il ya un problème que
l'agriculture
on se retrouve avec un un coup de un
coup de barre dans la tête en disant ah
mais c'est de la ghriba chine
moi j'aimerais que la la fnsea parce que
c'est pas tous les agriculteurs mais le
syndicat principal life est né ce soir
arrête de nous faire ce procès en agri
bashing il ya aucun agri bashing ajusté
fait et juste des faits aujourd'hui il
ya 30% d'oiseaux en moins dans les
campagnes il ya quasiment plus d'un
siècle dans certaines séries certaines
parties de la france et c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça il faut
que l'agriculture change
j'ai envie d'adresser le même message à
la fédération nationale des chasseurs
ils ne peuvent pas continuer à défendre
le pire du pire dans les pratiques de
chasse notamment la chasse aux espèces
qui sont aujourd'hui en danger les
espèces d'oiseaux qui sont en danger
donc je je je suis moi mais après à
assumer un discours virulent à l'égard
des fédérations un pad et pas des
individus mais des fédérations qui porte
aujourd'hui des choses extrêmement
radical dans leur façon de voir les
choses qui ne permettent pas les
évolutions nécessaires aujourd'hui et
encore une fois moi j'appelle à ce qu'on
construise des compromis mais que
évidemment c'est fédération arrête
d'être les les plus défenseur de tous
les pesticides les plus dangereux des
pratiques de chasse les plus cruels et
les plus dangereuses pour la
biodiversité et qu'on trouve enfin en
face de nous des gens raisonnables parce
que sinon sinon c'est la mairie de
bordeaux et la mairie de lyon
c'est ça qui va gagner en france si on
trouve pas les compromis parce que quand
je vous dise tout larguer des
impatiences c'est comme ça que ça finit
merci merci à toi yam il y avait
d'autres questions j'ai pas pu prendre
toutes les questions de tous nos amis
modem qui ont mis des questions sur sur
le fil des questions on essaiera d'en
débattre notamment à l'université 133
merci à vous d'avoir échangé sur le
sujet simplement je crois qu'on a vu que
notre mouvement est au coeur de ces
sujets là notre mouvementée son origine
le modem c'était en 2007 déjà des
questions écologiques qui se pose est
est donc on est dans cet équilibre là je
pense que je le dis en toute simplicité
c'est nous qu'avant la même réponse sur
le sujet et donc on va essayer de faire
autrement pour les populistes vert c'est
à dire qu'il s'y amuse imposer quelque
chose qui est trop sectaire trop violent
pour la le peuple français ne veut pas
et donc merci d'avoir ouvert ce débat
c'est qu'un début au modem mais entre un
emploi à proximité la biodiversité
climat l'agriculture et donc merci à
toutes et à tous sur blé bla à bientôt
et momar a évidemment au modem de la
biodiversité du climat et du
développement durable du moment qu'il
soit souhaitable
merci à vous